[Music]
the idea of creating artificial
creatures has obsessed us for millennia
but for the purposes of this exercise
before we go any further I'm going to
ask you to purge any of the following
thoughts from your head checklist
Hephaestus expelled from Olympus and
then built two servant robots the boot
of ant a hunter or spirit movement
machines of 12th century India made to
protect the relics of Buddha the
chess-playing Mechanical Turk just a
bloke in a box pulling levers Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein he walks he talks
not a lot else kubrick's how don't call
me Dave c-3po r2d2 canine ns2 and
seriously these are just numbers and
letters Robbie the robot robot lovers
Robocop
[Music]
feeling better okay let's get going I'm
Hanna Frey I'm an associate professor in
mathematics and I am AI curious and this
is deepmind
the podcast series where we look at the
fast moving story of artificial
intelligence we've been talking to the
scientists researchers and engineers
based at deepmind in London and we're
looking at how they're approaching the
science of AI and some of the tricky
decisions the whole field is wrestling
with at the moment so whether you just
want to know more or want to be inspired
on your own AI journey then this is the
place to be you see the thing is robots
cell
we've long lusted after the idea of
appending the natural order with human
ingenuity we just can't seem to leave it
alone and in this episode we are looking
at AI and robotics Marie Shanahan is a
senior scientist at deep mind he's also
a professor of cognitive robotics at
Imperial College London and growing up
Marie was utterly mesmerised by science
fiction so you can picture his face when
the Hollywood film director Alex Garland
approached him following the publication
of his book embodiment and the inner
life Alex contacted me and said oh I'm
writing a script for a film about AI and
consciousness and I read your book and
it you know helped to crystallize some
ideas and you like to chat about about
it and and so of course it was you know
it was a great opportunity to get
involved in a science-fiction film and
then and then to my great good fortune
it turned out to be an absolute cracker
and that is how Murray became scientific
advisor on the oscar-winning film ex
machina
I met with Murray to get a potted
history of AI more people tend to think
of AI is this very new thing a very a
very modern invention but it's actually
been around for quite a long time it has
the idea of artificial intelligence the
idea of making artificial creatures
dates back to Greek mythology but
there's a modern conception of AI
perhaps really dates back to Alan
Turing's paper published in the 1950s
where he first kind of asked the
question could a machine think and gave
a number of kind of refutations for
counter arguments to the idea that a
machine could think this is where the
Turing test this is that this famous
paper inaugurated the so-called Turing
test course cheering didn't call it the
Turing test which is the idea that we
should subject the machine to a test to
see whether it's basically whether it's
indistinguishable from a human in
dialogue the term artificial
intelligence was actually coined by John
McAfee a Stanford professor he was at
MIT at the time and John McAfee
organized a conference in 1956 bringing
together a lot of leading thinkers in
maths to try and scope out the idea of
building a thinking machine and he
coined the term artificial intelligence
what did they describe as at that time
how did they see artificial intelligence
John McCarthy in particular his idea of
artificial intelligence that he had in
mind was a kind of system that would
answer questions really and be able to
engage in dialogue with with humans
so something that you're talking to
although of course in those days it
wouldn't have been through speech it
would have been by typing in at the
keyboard and it was very much a
disembodied notion of artificial
intelligence so this system didn't have
a body and interact with a physical
world in the way that we do or animals
do or indeed that robots do so they
weren't really thinking about robotics
at that point I'm sort of imagining
something like how in 2001 a Space
Odyssey exact typing in Robbins yeah and
under kind of nice version you know that
their approach to artificial
intelligence was to build systems that
reasoned in logic and we now think of
that whole sort of approach to
artificial intelligence of using logic
and reasoning as so-called good
old-fashioned artificial intelligence or
Oh classical AI now I know I know I did
a bad thing there I mentioned how but
nobody ever said that this was gonna be
easy but to recap in classical AI you
have to write down a complete list of
rules for how you want your agent to
think if this happens then do this if
that happens then do that it's a nice
idea in theory but if your agent is
going to know how to handle every
possible scenario you can throw at it
it's going to need to be a long long
list there was a project called psych
which attempted to write out all the
rules of common sense to build an
enormous encyclopedic database of a
common sense so I mean there'll be
things like if you've got a container
and you put something in that container
and then move that container somewhere
else then the thing that was in it gets
moved as well then yeah stuff like that
you know and if you buy something and
pay for it you'll have less money than
you had in the first place
so do I think it's impossible to do that
I think it's impossible in practice
because it turns out that the sheer
number of rules that you would have to
write is absolutely enormous we might
have moved away from these long lists of
rules by now as a way to teach our
artificial intelligence in favor of
agents that can learn the rules for
themselves but the skills that we want
are AI to have like good old-fashioned
common sense are just as important now
as they ever were
[Music]
imagine one day long into the future a
wealthy computer scientist builds an AI
to manage his stamp collection he plugs
into the internet gives it access to his
bank account and sets in the challenge
to buy as many stamps as possible
at first the agent acts as its creator
intended signing up to eBay bidding on
stamps but after a while it gets another
idea more money equals more stamps so
why not start trading on the stock
market to make more money and it soon
realizes it can get the stamps cheaper
if it can get them at source so the
agent buys up a factory convert its
manufacturing process to stamp making
and goes on with achieving its goal but
of course the limiting factor here is
paper more paper more stamps so it
starts commanding forests to be felled
the wood to be processed all to feed its
single-minded ambition more stamps now
there's no denying that the AI is doing
what it was told but it's doing so at
any cost and any agent without some kind
of common sense will be at risk of
taking our instructions a bit too
literally this might be a bit of an
extreme example but Victoria crackovia a
research scientist at deep mind working
on AI safety is already seeing agents
that aren't exactly behaving in the way
their designers intended a reinforcement
learning agent that was playing a boat
racing game and the intended behavior
there was to go around the racetrack and
finish the race as soon as possible and
the agent was encouraged to do this by
having these little green squares along
the track that would give its rewards
and then with the agent figured out is
that instead of actually playing the
game it could be going around in circles
and hitting the same green squares over
and over again to rack up more points
then you have this this whole situation
with the boat going in circles and
crashing into everything and catching
and fire and still getting more points
than would otherwise get these kind of
situations are quite common
because you haven't ever stopped the AI
from doing that or told the AI that you
don't want it to do that that's a
perfectly sensible solution for it to
come across yeah from the perspective of
the AI it can't really tell that this
solution is achieved it's just something
that gives it a lot of reward so it can
necessarily distinguish between the
general solution and a really creative
solution that humans just haven't
foreseen there are plenty of examples
like this one team of researchers
created an agent inside a very simple
two-dimensional computer game and tossed
it with building itself a body to get
itself from the start line to the finish
line quite quickly it worked out that it
could just build itself taller and
taller and taller until it was as high
as the track was long and then just
flopped forwards to cross the line and
there was the agent playing the game of
Tetris which realized it could just
pause the game forever and never lose
but there is a balancing act here we
don't want our AI misbehaving but we
also don't want to restrict our agents
too much and this is part of what's
tricky about achieving safe behavior is
that we don't want to hamper the
system's ability to come up with really
interesting and innovative solutions
that we have not foreseen so we don't
just want human imitation we want
superhuman capabilities but without
unsafe behavior there is a very fine
line between a naughty algorithm and one
that's finding innovative solutions to
problems that humans haven't been able
to solve the AI doesn't know the
difference between the two it doesn't
understand what's really important to us
it doesn't have any common sense and
that means you have to be very careful
when you're setting up incentives and
rewards for your agents part of the
reason that this is so difficult is this
general perfect that's called good
hearts law and economics or good hearts
law says is that when a metric becomes a
target it ceases to be a good metric
a classic example of God arts law comes
from British India when authorities
offered cash rewards for dead Cobras as
a way to decrease the population of
snakes unbeknownst to the British the
local started to breed Cobras in order
to take advantage of the reward as soon
as the authorities found this out they
scrapped the scheme altogether and
revoked the rewards but now there were
these snake farms everywhere filled with
worthless Cobras so what did the locals
do release the Cobras into the country
resulting in an increase in the cobra
population this is what the scientists
call a specification problem when your
specified objective fails to bring about
the intended behavior this is generally
quite likely to happen because you my
preferences tend to be quite complex and
whenever we try to distill them into
some kind of specification or something
that we say we want it's going to be a
lot simpler than our real preferences
are and wouldn't necessarily capture
everything that's important to us let's
imagine we're living in the future where
robot Butler's are commonplace you
clearly specify the objective for your
robot it should serve you at all times
now how is that agent going to feel
about its own off switch your old always
has an incentives to preserve its own
function if it gets turned off they can
vacuum the floors anymore can't bring
you coffee it want to disable its off
switch for example Yan Leica is a senior
research scientist at deep mind also
working on AI safety if you turn off
then contact you the forest so if it
understands how the opposite of switch
mechanism works it would want to disable
it
what we want is you want our systems to
actually do something that is good for
us ready to do something that we
actually wanted not just like me
we want it but how do you get around
these kinds of problems well we already
know that writing a long list of do's
and don'ts won't work however long your
list gets you're always going to forget
something the new breed of learning
agents is going to need a different
approach
so one direction that we are pursuing is
learning your what functions for
reinforcement learning agents and you
can thing kind of think of this as
learning what your system should be
doing from human feedback so for example
in in one work that we did together with
open the eye is where we trained a
simulated robot to do a back flip and
the way this works is like the the robot
does some movement and then you watch a
video of their movement and you say two
videos and then you can compare which of
those looks more like a back flip yawns
experiment has a human sitting and
watching a screen looking at an AI
attempting to do a back flip each time
the human will feedback on whether the
attempt was good enough slowly nudging
the agent in the right direction
here is the key idea with constant human
feedback the human can communicate their
preferences without having to actually
specify them and risk oversimplifying
things in the process and after you like
a few hundred rounds of feedback the
robot can actually perform the black
flip it's kind of learn what the
objective should be that the objective
should be your back flip and what a back
flip is this is difficult to specify
precisely what a back flip would be I
mean so in my case like I can't do a
back fin right and but I can see if the
systems do back flips and in some ways
like this allows us to get superhuman
capability the AI then is essentially
being rewarded by pleasing the human in
a way exactly okay so we can we can do a
little experiment I'll try to teach you
to make a sound okay by giving feedback
so you'll make two sounds mm-hmm and
that
you wish and Intel sounds is closer to
you what I have in mind okay yeah does
that sound good so I'm being a are you
yeah you're being the I and I'm being
the human teacher and you're training me
essentially with reinforcement learning
and my reward function is getting you to
be happy you know what that's like
so the reward function here is like
something is in my mind right and I'm
trying to teach you so you can't
directly see the reward you can only see
like my feedback but my objective is to
get you to say you like the sound I'm
making exactly okay listen think 80
cents let's go for meat and this went on
for a while beep beep and but with Ian's
feedback we got beep and beep I go with
the first one absolutely nowhere
the expiration problem actually if I was
actually I have and I've gone through
ten thousand iterations by now well you
have a human the loop that you've use
all of that so it is it is kind of slow
but this is actually a problem that we
have in our assistance is that like in
order to give useful feedback you have
to have useful examples right in this
case you produced sounds that are very
similar and like the son I had in mind
was like very different so I really like
have the opportunity to give you a very
useful feedback but this is like
basically this is the same thing would
come up with a bad flip right like if
your robot just like lies on the floor
like two different ways like what are
you gonna do but you would hope though
after I'd had maybe a hundred goes at it
I'd end up with something that began to
approach what you had in mind yeah
definitely there finally is it like oh
no I'm not asking any questions I'm like
I'm in AI
I mean ideally this is at some point
this is what we'd want our systems to be
able to do I know just like describe
this on to you in natural language and
then you could just do it that would be
really cool right yeah so this is the
kind of research that we want to do
in the future that's like the kind of
system so we want to figure out how to
build okay actually everything I've done
so far has been like voices you didn't
say that it had to be a vocal thing did
you yeah okay hang on all right how
about this how about a service and the
first one the only problem was setting
up reinforcement learning with a human
standing over it offering feedback at
every stage is that it is monumentally
slow now it would take an agent months
if not years to master a game like Atari
and even then you need to hire a pretty
large group of poor students to do the
boring job of supplying feedback in real
time but there is an alternative you can
rustle up a slightly more sophisticated
learning partnership so what we do when
we actually build these systems is we
don't literally do the experiment that
we did now and instead we have we train
an eel network a second meal network
that learns how I would give feedback as
the human and then the the neural
network can teach you because I can just
oversee all of the things you're doing
by now neural networks have become
really good at spotting patterns dog not
dog backflip not backflip perhaps you
don't always need a human in the loop
laborious ly giving feedback why not
have two agents one attempting the task
and the other deciding if it succeeded
the reason why this works very well is
because evaluating the objective is an
easier task than producing the behavior
that achieves it so you can have like D
for example and the backflipping robot
all the neural network has to do is like
look at what the robot is doing and see
whether it's a back flip
you're listening to deepmind the podcast
a window on AI research but of course
where this stuff really comes alive is
where you take the ideas take them out
of a computer simulation and allow your
imagination to roam into the world of
embodied AI robots that learn how to
cook robots that learn how to pack fruit
in crates tuck you into bed and perform
backflips it's time to visit the deep
mind robotics laboratory this is your
lab this is where you spend your days
this is jackie kay a software engineer
packed to the rafters with robots
it's very cool we're basically running
out of the best it's quite noisy in here
yeah we got a lot going on today
this place isn't quite the high-security
basement laboratory you'd imagine there
are half assembled robot arms and
machine parts scattered all around the
place some look like mechanical hands
others quite a lot like great kitchenaid
style food mixers and curiously there is
a SpongeBob SquarePants mascot hanging
from the ceiling much of the work in
this room focuses on getting robotic
arms to learn how to do simple tasks
each robot is bolted to the floor in its
own cordoned off area and as we come in
the door there's one that's caught my
eye
now that game that you play when you're
a kid
you have tennis bat and a ball attached
to it and you kind of play tennis when
you're wearing this sort of looks like a
robotic version of that it's called the
ball in a cup oh she is it is exactly
that it is trying to swing the ball into
that little basket so you can see it
swinging the ball around the little it's
actually tracking position of the yellow
ball and it's trying to minimize the
distance from that ball to the area
inside the basket
not exactly a smooth delivery of the
ball into the cup more a slightly clumsy
lucky flip of course if your ultimate
goal was to make a perfect cup and ball
playing robot you could directly program
a machine to do that without fail you
can build robots that perform simple
tasks in much more elegant ways but
that's not really the point here's why I
had so senior research scientist a deep
mind a robot is a machine that can take
over a task one can say in the broadest
sense that your dishwasher at home and
your vacuum cleaner both robots because
they do something complex they run on
their own they have some autonomy to
them of course we also like to think
about robots as having some intelligence
and then you get more into the realm of
a robot with AI and I'm particularly
interested in saying how can we take
this a technology and make it work on
robots so that we have embodied AI and
that is an important distinction the
focus of the research in this robotics
lab isn't to create robots that are told
what to do but to have them learn their
own skills much in the same way that
other agents do here
the robots here are what's known as
embodied AI so let's say yeah the task
is
a robot that's trying to lift a box is
the programmer in a kind of traditional
setting would say go to box open hand
move hand you know 30 centimeters
towards the box close hand but this is
different yeah this is sort of taking
what we want and then figuring out how
to accomplish what we want every few
seconds this particular robot will have
an attempt at getting the ball into the
cup before pausing resetting and having
another go and every now and then by
chance the ball lands in the cup and the
robot is rewarded with a positive score
just like if it was playing a computer
game the reset in between their training
episodes where it untangle itself or
flips the ball out of the cup those are
scripted but then when it actually tries
to accomplish the task that is a policy
which it has taught itself through
experience over time from everything it
learns and the schools it receives the
robot builds a picture of how the ball
moves and how this relates to the robots
own movement so it had we come in right
at the very beginning then what would we
see just completely random noise
probably very chaotic
oh did he want ours it didn't wanna that
was Wow
that wasn't like three seconds so will
it know now that that movement gave it a
successful results yes and so the next
time that we see this do we expect it to
be better than when we walked in yeah it
will try similar actions that gave it a
positive reward or a success it's just
so assessing that quite smartly right
now yes there is a big advantage to
getting the AI to figure out tasks for
itself you'll end up with a robot that
is much more flexible out of the box it
doesn't matter what you want it to do
tire not stacks and bricks peel a banana
just as long as you can clearly
communicate your objective you don't
need to specify a long list of
instructions for these robots and
perhaps they'll come up with a new way
of banana peeling that you haven't
thought of but there's also a big
drawback in training AI that has a
physical body they are much slower to
learn than all of the disembodied agents
you'll find in this building the ones
that only exist inside a computer
other researchers are able to take
advantage of parallelism that is they
run their environments in simulation on
computers they can run them in parallel
on hundreds of compute different
computers we're all gathering data about
this environment they're trying to learn
something about we only have what
four robots here and there frequently
not running the same experiment so it
might just be one robot collecting data
and that means our training will be
orders of magnitude slower for
comparable tasks compared to ones that
are running in simulation on computers
progress is slower in this room and you
can tell the agents here are a little
less accomplished in another corner
another robot is trying to pick up a
Lego brick with a hooked gripping device
kind of like a claw and there's a rather
ominous box of mangled Lego bricks next
to it and I think this one has some
shaping to close its gripper when it
detects it's close to the brick it also
has a fixed training time so after some
number of seconds it will just get done
go back to the start and then try it
Lego is sort of this building block to
general-purpose manipulation if you know
if we can stack like two bricks together
we can then do kind of I'm sure you're
gonna break it
oh it's fine sorry I got distracted by
smashing up the legs there is real
potential here and so Jackie and the
team are constantly trying to find ways
of speeding up that learning process one
technique that we are looking into in
order to and that some researchers here
have done really cool work on in the
past is something we call center wheel
or simulation to reality transfer which
shows are you where you take a
simulation on a computer that models
your robot and we can learn kind of in
broad strokes what the robot is like how
its actions affect its environment
and how it can do something similar to a
task that's trying to learn in real life
so once we figure out all of that in
simulation without even touching the
real robot we can transfer the data it's
collected onto real hardware so you can
cheat basically you can cheat by
imagining the real robot within a
computer calculating all the physics
that would happen in real life and then
use the same techniques you use that
army of computers to give you a bit of a
head start before you even apply it to
the real physical robot exactly
so the real robots end up acting the
same way as your simulated robots do
well they start out acting the same way
as their simulated robots do and then as
they train more they might start
behaving slightly differently or better
when they go into reality using
simulation might give you a head start
on reality but it's never going to match
precisely the real robot has to contend
with grip friction gravity wear and tear
all of which play important roles in the
real world but none of which will be
perfectly represented inside the
computer and all of that means well I
think science fiction may have set some
false expectations one thing that's I am
a little bit surprised but being here
don't take this wrong way but these
robots are a bit rubbish yes it's true I
mean we've got a lot of work to do but
as with so much of what happens here at
deep mind it's not so much about these
exact datums
it's not about cup and ball or Lego
stacking it's about the type of
intelligence being acquired and how that
fits into the bigger picture we want to
demonstrate general purpose as we go
along targets
physical intentions great so contrasting
that with kind of intelligence that's
not embodied which maybe can learn
leggins or maybe even understand
language physical intelligence is
looking at how physical actions of your
body affect the real world so we want to
take a wide variety of tasks playing
with objects using tools maybe walking
around
in the future and we want to show that
robots can teach themselves those how to
do those tasks in the physical world in
the physical world
yes but physical intelligence is of
course only one type of intelligence one
string to the robots bow and deep mind
as we've seen dares to dream big here's
Marie Shanahan with the Big Finish the
holy grail of AI research is to build
artificial general intelligence so to
build AI that is as good at doing an
enormous variety of tasks as we humans
are so so we are not specialists in that
kind of way we you know a young adult
human can learn to do a huge number of
things you can learn to make food you
can learn to make a company you can
learn to build things to fix things you
can do so many things to have
conversations to rear children so all
those things and we really want to be
able to build AI that has the same level
of generality as that if you want to
know more about robotics and technical
AI safety then head over to the show
notes where you can also explore the
world of AI research beyond deep mind
and we'd welcome your feedback or your
questions on any aspects of artificial
intelligence that we're covering in this
series so if you want to join in the
discussion or point us to stories or
resources that you think other listeners
would find helpful then please let us
know you can message us on Twitter or
you can email us podcast at deepmind
comm